you've made a great decision and i say
this as
impartially as i possibly can but this
podcast
is it's really the reason why i started
the diver ceo it's to hear these kinds
of stories from these
kinds of people and i've got to be
honest with you i
spent about a year asking this person to
come on this podcast and have a
conversation with me
today's guest is dr aria and he's been
on the podcast once before he's a
a world renowned high performance coach
and he works with some of the world's
most accomplished
athletes actors and everyone in between
as they try and reach a mindset state
that is
conducive with success with happiness
and with overall fulfillment
but he's not here to talk about that
today he's here to talk about something
very very different something
uncomfortable
something unimaginable so without
further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
sometimes in life you have these
unbelievable
somewhat cruel coincidences that occur
that it's hard to make sense of and last
time you came on this podcast i would
define it as for me anyway
a pretty cruel coincidence because
we had a conversation um to do with life
generally and
and success and the mindset and
psychology and all the things that
you're an expert on
and for whatever reason that day
i decided that i wanted to spend 30
minutes
talking about marriage cheating love
and asking you these um very personal
questions about monogamy which i've
never done before with any guest ever
and which i really had no place or
reason to ask you more than anyone else
and it just feels to me
for what we're going to talk about in
part today that that was a bit of a
cruel coincidence and you know one of
the questions i asked you was
um do you believe in monogamy and then i
asked you
can you love someone and cheat on them
and when i listened to that podcast back
i now
noticed um why you laughed
because it wasn't you laughed yeah and
it wasn't a normal laugh
it was like a real belly laughing right
yeah like a bit of a nervous belly laugh
yeah after we came off air on that
podcast
you told me something and uh it
even gives me goosebumps now thinking
about what you said and it gave the
whole team in the room who
overheard our conversation goosebumps as
well so
after our 30-minute conversation about
marriage monogamy and cheating and love
what did you say to me
i told you a story yeah and that was uh
about two weeks earlier i'd been
traveling back from london
home and i got out of the train station
and my wife picked me up and we got into
the car
and we had planned to go and have a
brunch at my favorite
little spot they do amazing corvo's
rancho sauce
i was very excited and she said let's go
straight home i've made sandwiches
and she doesn't make great sandwiches so
i said no no i think the brunch is a
better option
and she said no there's something that i
need to tell you
and i said is it bad and she said yes
and i said is that about the marriage
and she said yes and then we began to
drive back
and i had the sinking feeling in me
and we drove for about five minutes in
silence and then i went to put my hand
on her lap and she said don't
don't touch me because you won't want
you after i've told you what's happened
and that's whenever it drops and i
remember that
10-minute drive back home then felt like
an eternity
i was just looking out the window and we
got home
we got into the house into the kitchen
and i was standing
by the kitchen table hands rested on it
and i said what's happened and she said
i've been having an affair
with a man from work
and i remember just tears began to
stream i didn't move
completely motionless tears began to
stream
and then she said and that's not all and
she said
i'm pregnant with this child
and in that moment
i felt like i lost a lot you know i'd
lost
my wife i'd lost the life we created
i'd lost the dog
our home her my parents-in-law her
family
everything that really held dear if
someone said what makes a meaningful
life
i would have described these things and
it felt like they'd just been snatched
away just
came crumbling down like a
house of cards didn't fast forward two
weeks
and steve said
and i remember because the first thing
no no it's fascinating because the first
thing you asked
was you're married right and i do this
high-pitched laugh and i go
yes and then and then the conversation
blow down and and it's themes i'd really
thought about
can you love someone and cheat on them
does monogamy exist is it natural
are we set up to live a life where we're
in one relationship
with one person only and so with the
past
18 months it's been a process and some
of these themes have been very real to
me
i just as i reflect on that conversation
and when i played it back
um after you told me so we come off air
we stood next to the table
and the microphones and you you
explained to me what's happened yeah i'm
first time in my life completely
speechless and
the thing that blew me away even more so
than what you'd said to me
was your ability to be so calm and
rational
and objective in the answers you gave
and even when i listen back now
although there was that laugh which was
a bit of an indication um
you were able to speak about someone
betraying you or being deceitful with a
level of calmness
and apparent um emotional
uh sort of restraint that i i just
admired so much from someone that was
right in the middle of the emotional
hurricane and had just been victim of
that act and
um you said that you know about the
topic of monogamy
how did that change your opinion and
and also the subsequent 18 months of
processing on the topic of monogamy
[Music]
so as a quick aside i like that analogy
and we touch upon it briefly about the
hurricane
and and it's funny actually because a
friend of mine showed me
a book about a week ago and it was
different
personality profiles depending on the
day that you'd been born on
and whenever we looked mine up there's a
little meditation at the end a summary
and it said the stillest part of the
hurricane
is its center and that
essentially has been uh a philosophy
that's guided
my life where sometimes there's a storm
and it's horrendous and it's raging but
if you can cultivate that sense of
stillness and calmness and clarity deep
within you
no matter what life throws at you
you will be okay because the second part
of
whenever i was told that news and and
the tears were
streaming and i felt that sense of loss
and overwhelming sadness
it was a remarkable moment where in that
instant
and i can only describe it as a whisper
i heard a whisper within me
as if it was resonating from my heart
that
all will be well forwards all will be
well
all will be well and i knew even then i
knew whenever
you know this tumultuous emotion i knew
everything's going to be okay
i will get through this i'm going to
have to walk through the desert and i'm
going to have to endure
a horrific amount of an emotional level
but it's all going to be fine
how did you know that i think it's
something that i've
cultivated over over 10 15 years and
that's why i do what i do now because i
want to help other people to reach that
stage
and and it began on a journey of um
buddhist exploration and understanding
the nature of life
and i came to this realization that life
involves suffering
there's no promise that it's going to be
happy-go-lucky
and really pleasant all the time really
horrific things
happen in life and on one level there's
no way that we can ever rationally
explain it away
sometimes bad things happen but it
doesn't end there
it's a bit like that line that someone
once said to century whenever you're
suffering don't
ask god why am i suffering ask
god where are you taking me
and so i've developed this ability to
begin to view my life as though it's
happening to someone else
as though the experience the thoughts
the emotions
are are something that i can almost take
it back on and have perspective
and i can see it and i can feel it but i
know
that my thoughts that isn't just who i
am my emotions isn't just through my and
that's a temporary experience
and and throughout my life no matter
what has happened even whenever it's
been brutal
it's often shifted being a new
trajectory and there's been
a new meaningful life ahead of me and i
knew even then
she's going to be okay she'll be okay
it's going to be a tough road for her to
but she'll be okay
and it's gonna be a tough road for me to
you but i will be okay
anger so many people in that situation
whether rightly or wrongly just because
of the way that they are yeah would have
reacted with
anger and for some reason you were both
calm in telling me
you're calm now and the this remarkable
thing which i
i think i i struggle to understand a
little bit
is one of your first concerns was her
well-being
versus your own why
because i loved her and
i was in the practice of of placing her
emotional well-being
and her happiness on
the same level of mine if not sometimes
first and foremostly but at least so on
an equal playing field
and and i was just so in that habit and
that was the toughest thing to let go of
the thing that i still struggle with
today and i'm still
it's the one part that i realized the
other day
that i still had a fear of upsetting her
or her not being okay
and so that's something which just
just really developed and and was so
ingrained
and it's interesting on the point of
anger
if you said like your wife
partner for 10 years married for five
has an affair and is pregnant with
another man's child how will you react i
would have said anger
i would i'd be furious but it wasn't
there
at least not initially it was this
overwhelming sense of sadness it was
just that sense of loss of knowing that
again that she's potentially done
something that she might regret for a
long time and i don't want anyone to go
through that experience where they feel
like they've
[ __ ] up hugely even if the the future
is positive in that moment
my senses there will be regret or at
least shame
and so it was a sadness because i was
connected to the loss the sense of loss
of
losing things i held dear feels like
you're living outside your body
a little bit i guess that's what
self-awareness is or at least emotional
awareness awarenesses because you're
being able to see that situation which
is utterly horrific
for anyone yeah um from as you say from
like a bird's eye view
as if you've like yeah looking down on
it
and that's allowing you not to just feel
your own emotions but to feel
empathy towards theirs yeah and i think
i think that's the path
in my eyes that's the path to
enlightenment and i'm not saying that i
am enlightened but i think we're all on
that path i'm all progressing through it
and for me that's what awareness is it's
being able to experience
internally your thoughts and your
emotions and externally what's happened
as if it's happening to someone else
you're like holding them out in front of
you and analyzing them right
but if you're not holding them out in
front of you and it's happening within
you then you are just
almost like a passenger on a roller
coaster whereas
holding them out in front of you kind of
makes you the the conductor or the
roller coaster or at least uh
able to yeah understand and if you can
understand then you can address and
you can overcome totally i love it
whenever you're holding it really close
to you
you're fused with it anything that
happens instantly will
provoke a reaction whether or not it's
emotional or behavioral
but when you hold it in front of you
there's a bit more space now you still
experience it
it was a brutal couple of months i cried
every day
uh for maybe three months for hours
hours i would i would walk and i'd
process what happened
and if you want we can talk about that
at some point um about my process of
moving through it
but yes it was i'm not going to say it
wasn't
um emotionally painful but
i wasn't defined by that pain and that
was just a part that i was experiencing
let's talk about that so a lot of people
experience
grief in many forms and this somewhat
feels like this the central emotion
you described as a loss it feels like a
form of grief yeah what was your process
for moving from you know finding out
that it happened to where you are today
where you're
you know you've quote unquote processed
it i imagine
as much as you might have been able to
at this stage yeah
some yeah what was your process
where i think people often um
catch themselves in a in a counter but
productive cycle
is whenever they try and avoid
experiencing what they're experiencing
they try and shun it lock it
away put it in a box disconnect from it
deny it
and they just focus on the future and
where i'm going and they might try and
rationalize it uh this happened because
of x or because of y
and then they try and forge ahead and i
think it comes back to bite them at some
point
the simplest truth is that we can only
ever experience
one moment at a time and i remind myself
of that
i don't need to think about right now
the financial separation the divorce
what it means about
friends or family or or will i
meet someone again or how long will it
be or what will my life look like or
where am i going to live so many
different factors that could be
overwhelming
i just decided to deal with one moment
at a time all i need to do
is deal with this one moment and what is
this one bringing me
and accepting and welcoming it sounds
strange but welcoming whatever comes up
and so whatever emotion came up i didn't
try and push it away or shunt it or deny
it or negate it
i let it i let it sit and that's why i
cried so much
because there was so much sadness did
you write down the emotions you're
experiencing
so i didn't write down the emotions but
what i did
in the next step is so the first step
was
awareness and accepting whatever
emotions i felt
and i'm seeing that they come and then
they go you know that there'd be moments
where i'd be laughing with my brother
and then crying a minute later and then
talking about something else
the second step was reminding myself of
reality
because i was so ingrained in
in an internal model of what life looked
like
i have a strong
stable marriage in which my partner
subconsciously uh you know implicitly i
believe
is faithful we're meant to be together
we're going to be together for the next
50
60 years until one of us dies
we're going to have children together
that was my internal model
and i had to rip it apart i had to take
it down i had to dismantle
it and i had to remind myself of the
reality
of the situation i had to accept it
i had to accept it's over it's not going
to change
there's no going back the final nail is
in the coffin
and you need to take that on board
and i'd also write any i'd write down
reminders of
of what had happened and i also wrote
down
any insights i had about the situation
that i could remind myself of
and i wrote down how i wanted to handle
this
process um i can actually read a few out
if you want please
please i've got um so i i literally
would just write them down on my phone
um and so afterwards i began to split
them up
into different sections but this one was
for
the process hold yourself to the highest
standard
choose actions that you can be proud of
how you get through this process is more
important than how quickly
you get through this process because for
me it was important
that i still lived with personal
integrity that i didn't
that i wasn't warped or changed or
um consumed with
vengeance or acted in ways that was out
of spite or out of emotion i wanted to
be able to look back on this in 12
months 18 months time
and still feel good about it have a
clear conscience still able to put my
head down
and feel as though i handled that to the
best of my ability
with god you can get through this you
can become stronger wiser
more caring more compassionate and more
loving
and that's another thing that actually
the deepest moments of
suffering can actually be opportunities
for growth
even if you don't want it there's
something there that that you can learn
and
can grow from you don't need anything
from her
anymore um
and there and then different reminders
you have nothing to feel bad about
you aren't responsible you have nothing
to feel guilty about
nothing because there were moments where
my mind would almost begin to
in a way play a trick on me and begin to
try and create
reasons um to feel bad or to try and
create
shame and at those times while i would
accept what came up
i decided not to pursue that line of
thinking because
that didn't fit whenever i was calm and
clear this came to me and so i'd write
down whatever came to me whenever i was
in a place of
wisdom then when the emotion hit
and i'm not seeing clearly and i've got
on a clouded lens this little baby
became my best friend
because i'd go back to and i'd remind
myself and then it would reshift
my mental paradigm i have this um before
please do keep your phone open because i
want to hear the rest of this all right
but i have this um
analogy i make in moments where i
experience a very similar thing but i'm
going to say one
example yeah it's it's the closest i can
come to
resonating with what your experience is
i was dating this girl
and i broke up with her and three days
later
i find out that she's had sex with
someone else right
and i can only the way that i described
it was
i'm flying on this plane and i'm the
pilot
and then suddenly when i fight when i
when i look down and hear the news that
she's just slept with someone
somebody else yeah it was like terror
stormed the cockpit
and they chucked the [ __ ] rational
pilot out
and they were threatening to crash the
whole [ __ ] thing
and my whole objective as the pilot is
to get back into the cockpit before they
crash this plane into the side of a
mountain
because if they crash the plane i'm
[ __ ] and so yeah what i wanted to do
was lose my integrity yeah i wanted to
crash the plane i wanted to
get her back take revenge tell her she's
a this this and this and this and this
and it was this because i've got to a
place of where i'm able to hold
situations out in front of me a little
bit more
than i ever was you know in the past i
was at war with myself
yeah it was the terrorists on one end
telling me to crash the plane and the
pilot saying
you've been here before you know you
just need to keep the plane in the air
until you
yeah yeah and and i and i'm going for a
run i'm like steve go to the gym
go for a run yeah clear your head i'm at
the gym the terrorists that you know and
i'm like
i'm going to finish i'm going to finish
back in and then i'll come back
yeah and the crazy conclusion to all of
this was my friend called me
and said a few things to me about
um why she did what she did yeah my
friend said to me
remember steve you rejected her she
really really really likes you and she's
done this as a way
to make herself feel better for the
rejection that you gave her
and it sounds like such a pathetic thing
to say but what it made me realize in
that moment
was much of the reason why the
terrorists had stormed the cockpit was
my ego was bruised
and the thing that coached those
terrorists out the cockpit
was my friend massaging my ego again
and and letting me know that some of
those stories we sometimes tell
ourselves when we get rejected about
why we got rejected yeah weren't true
it's not because you're not enough
it's in fact because of something you've
done and that was the reason
why i managed to take control of the
cockpit i did nothing
i didn't punish her in any way didn't
even mention it and it was and
so yeah um but please two things come to
me there
uh one is this uh emotion of anger
so fascinatingly nine to five percent of
the emotion for me was sadness
five percent was anger and the anger
struck early on it was the first
night and i remember my brother had
come over and was staying with me and i
woke up in the middle of the night
the night of that day that she told me
and
it was like my body was burning
i haven't experienced anger like that
before it was
it was almost like i was a flame i was
uh
just infused with rage
and i began and i really feel for my
brother having to witness this but i was
just
moving up and down shouting
as loudly as i could my wife my house
my wife my house and for five minutes
it was like a supernova it just was
just seething
and then it burnt out
and i cried and i fell asleep and and
the next day and then the anger didn't
really come much it would come now and
again but what i realized was
the anger was intimately attached to my
ego
the anger came whenever i was attached
to my ego and i'm very fortunate that
i'm able to detect from my ego
the majority of the time but when i
didn't
that's when it hurt because it came
about my wife
as if i own her as if there's ownership
as if
it's a part of me i don't own her
she's free my house
i didn't even own the house the mortgage
company did
you know but as soon as we link it to
ourselves and make it about us
yeah then it it's
it's a place of vulnerability because
you're getting inflicted it's like
getting stabbed in the heart
you feel that but it's an illusion
because we are not
our ego you know we can see our ego and
have a relationship to our ego but once
we're fused with it we're in trouble
and the other part of it is that because
i don't want to come across like a saint
like
i didn't have dark thoughts or
you know i wasn't angry and i just
handled it with grace the entire time
but i operate from a principle that the
mind has a mind of its own and i think
we talked about it last time
but essentially your mind will populate
your head with thoughts automatically
you're not asking for them
it'll just come up with judges
evaluations
assessments predictions about the future
past memories imagine scenarios
you know if i said okay steve don't
think about anything right now just for
10 seconds have a complete blank mind
and i'm going to say a word but don't
think about anything okay so we'll just
do it now don't think about a thing
birthday okay right
so even though you were attempting not
to think about your mind came up with it
automatically
and from my
perspective we are not our thoughts we
have thoughts
our mind comes up with thoughts but
that's not me i am the observer of the
thought
now why is that important because my
mind should come up
with really brutal thoughts what
thoughts like torturing the guy
really yeah getting in a car finding him
shooting in the back of the van and
doing this elaborate
elaborate of of what i would do to him
absolutely because
my mind was thinking about about
seeking vengeance justice justin justice
and
it was like a hollywood movie and
somehow no one found out
i went back along the date you know
and so yes you can have those or
whenever i was in deep pain
the thought of ending my life popped
into my head
i didn't have any intent i wasn't making
any plans i didn't
want to kill myself but my mind
wanted a way out of the pain
it was suffering and it wanted an end to
it and what is one option
killing yourself and so when i've got a
different relationship though with
these thoughts when i think about
torturing someone
or i think or when my mind comes up with
a thought of torturing someone
or my mind comes up with the thought of
[Music]
taking my life
there's no judgment i don't think oh
that means i must want to do it
or that means that i will do it or that
means i'm a bad person
or that means that i'm
evil it just means my mind
i think what is my mind trying to do is
it's trying to solve a solution
and it's probably struggling to cope and
it's trying to find a way to make me
feel better
nia on this podcast who came on this
podcast talked about how the mind is
actually
you know people think we're in the
search of pleasure but the mind is
programmed to
avoid discomfort yeah so we're
constantly in trying to seek you know
avoid it and that's why we procrastinate
because we've got a big project which is
yeah we might not feel competent to
complete or
you know we're a bit there's a feeling
of discomfort around it so we go and
wash the dishes we'll do the hoovering
yeah um on the on the you mentioned
wanting to torture this man
well i know right so like a moment of
the mind having
what my mind did steve you want to
clarify you didn't want to your mind
wanted to i'm a peace loving kind of guy
but i wanted to know how do you feel
about him
so it's really interesting i um
this stage the the process went
awareness and acceptance uh how i wanted
to handle the process
and then at some point i realized
i needed to find forgiveness
i'm quite a simple person and i don't i
don't like having a lot of
items or objects or physical possessions
and i don't like having a lot of
emotional baggage either
i want to travel light you know i want
to travel so lightly i could pass
through the eye of a needle
so to speak and the weight
of
anger or resentment or
[Music]
the feelings of betrayal
were weighing me down and i wanted to
forgive her and i wanted to
forgive him and honestly you could view
as ultimately selfish
because it's not going to impact their
life but it's going to make mine a lot
easier
and during lockdown i was in california
and i was lucky because in santa barbara
where i was staying the mayor didn't
close the beaches
because there's a lot of families there
and he said as long as you uh socially
distance it's fine
and i'd run along the beach and i had
this process
where i would say out loud
i would imagine her and i would say i
forgive you
i'm sending you my love and i wish you
all the best for the future
and i processed so much by that at that
point because i've been able to
understand and see her situation
and in my mind i have an idea of how it
was created and why it unfolded
and so there was compassion there and i
was able to reach that really
relatively quickly that that was easy
the hard part was with him
because i didn't know him
i didn't know his personality his
background
who he was he could be a great friend
and
an excellent son or
[Music]
potentially a very loving partner
but all i knew about him was that he
was prepared to take certain actions
and so whenever i tried it with him and
i'd say i forgive you
it was like there was a knot and a wince
and i'm like
and i would say and i'm sending you my
love
i don't wish you all for the future
but you're still imagining pulling up in
that van and jumping out and
blindfolding
[Music]
and so but i would just notice that i
don't know the tension there
and and actually i will say this was a
year after
i'd heard the news i didn't try and do
this initially i think it would have
been
uh premature to have attempted this
whenever i wasn't in a space where i had
a lot more clarity and
groundedness and and and process the
emotion the emotion wasn't being clouded
at this point
now what am i holding on to
and for a matter of weeks five six weeks
i was running two three times a week and
i would just try that
try that process and then one day it was
it was remarkable
i was running along and i said i forgive
you
and it was nothing and then i said
and i'm sending you my love and i felt
easy
and i said and i wish you all the best
for the future and i could tell
that i meant it for them or
their baby you know for them to gather
the family and i felt at peace
and it's a bit like that saying my yoke
is easy my burden is light
now genuinely it sounds strange but
i don't really feel anything for them
it's almost as if
you know if you came to me and said um
i've got a friend
called mike and he's going through a
really difficult time
he was involved in a really complicated
emotional relationship
um would you mind sending out positive
thoughts to him and sing a prayer for
him
i'd say sure like he hasn't ever done
anything to me i don't have any
connection with him
no problem it's almost that sort of
relationship now where
they're just other people on their
journey and i had that shared history
with
with my wife which i look upon
fondly particularly the first eight
years we had a wonderful
marriage for a long time but there's no
emotional
tinge there's it's like an emotional
umbilical cord i'm almost
imagining it it's a letting go yeah it's
a letting go
and so that was that was a part that for
me because i think there comes a time
where you have to say okay
i process it i've processed it
how long do i want to hold on to it for
now and that's becomes
my own choice do i want to carry this
and let it define me
or do i want to finally let it go and
see it float down the river
and i think you know even you're someone
that has a remarkable
ability to practice like self-awareness
and you know you have that sort of like
emotional awareness as well and it's
good to hear i think for everybody
listening to this
that even your process to from finding
it out
to you know being
emotionally unattached to the matter to
the point that you can forgive both of
them
wasn't linear at all it was up it was
down it was up it was down and it was
long
and i think people sometimes um think
that
their experience of rejection or deceit
or
you know um any of these things
is uniquely bad because their process
to recovery per se isn't linear
and it's long and it feels like the more
i've talked about this topic and the
more people i've met and you know from
hearing your experiences
that in fact is the only way out and i
actually think realizing that that's the
only way out will make your process
out of that deceit or betrayal
feel normal and natural
and okay and therefore acceptable and
and i think that's a really important
point that you've made
through the story you've told absolutely
and each person's journey will be unique
and there will be peaks and troughs and
it'll wax and wane
and i'm very aware that it's possible
that my journey
happened over a relatively short period
of time because of
my history my background as a
psychologist as a high performance
expert this is the area that i deal with
it's about developing emotional
resilience
it's how do you help people to cope with
high stakes environments when they've
lost a sense of balance in their life
when they're struggling in the
relationships whenever they
experience something in life which
throws them how do you get back up
this is what i've been trained to do for
15 years isn't it weird
that life sent you this challenge yeah
when you think about
your experience isn't it it must be a
part of you that because i think i would
i would think to myself
life is testing me to see if i can deal
with the worst
and still maintain the values and
principles that i spouse like yeah
it it sounds this will sound really odd
uh but i almost felt at times i thought
in a way
i'm so lucky because i'm so lucky that
i am where i am when this happened if
this had happened 10 years ago
i would have been in a vastly different
space why
because i struggled 10 years to cope
with what life gave me on an emotional
level
and i would react out of the emotion so
i'd experience it and then i would just
react and essentially that's when we
make terrible decisions oh you crashed
the plane
oh we crashed plane if you look at nasa
um
astronauts they prepare
for uh the sequence of events leading up
to launch
and they run through that over a hundred
times
from putting on the kit traveling down
to the launch
space to what could go wrong and they
rehearse and they run it through
and it's a way of being able to stay
calm
whenever there is uncertainty or
turbulence or danger or threat
because that's whenever that's the
person you really want to be whenever
there's an emergency
like we talked about in the podcast you
want to be the person that still
has an air a pocket a space of clarity
that isn't affected so that even though
you're experiencing all these emotions
on a very physical level
deep down you're still grounded
you can take it and so from where i was
i did feel as though
i'm fortunate that life is thrown at me
something that
in my mind was one of the worst things
that i could experience
there's lots of worse things without
shadow of a doubt but it was a big one
um and find a way to move through and
incredibly it's informed
even even my work because in the last
year
again whether it's coincidence or not i
don't know the number of clients i've
been working with on relationship
issues has gone up exponentially and
it's
issues centered on a loss of connection
a loss of intimacy
betrayal confusion how do you
how do you stay true to who you are in a
relationship with someone else
where you feel like there's a shift or
you wake up one day and you're in a
space where
you don't know how you got there where
you become like best friends living
together rather than the passionate
lovers you were
10 years ago you talked there a second
about the calm that
astronauts are trained to develop and
how crucial that is to making good
decisions i
i saw this quote the other day and it
said when emotions go go up
intellect comes down yeah and um i was
thinking about just them as you said
that i was thinking what are the factors
that make somebody
not calm and then i thought and they
kind of answered myself okay so it's we
talked about the ego
playing a big role and so i guess my
conclusion there is the people who will
struggle to maintain their calm in
situations like that
that are so personally associated are
those with
the lowest self-esteem and the most
fragile ego and it feels like the work
that you've described that you've done
over the last 10 years
is really like building your self-esteem
and really
in some respects a separation from ego
yeah you've nailed it one we know
on a neural level so we know from
neuroimaging studies that when we
experience emotion
the prefrontal cortex they part the
brain responsible for
judgment decision making impulse control
planning goes offline it shuts down
so we don't have access to that
creativity
the wisdom that we have usually
and again absolutely i think the journey
for me the journey of
of life involves developing a robust
sense of self
a sense of self that is unshakable
that is immovable that still experiences
life
and the whole gamut of emotions and and
the beauty and loveliness of life
and also the darkness and the
destruction of life
but isn't impacted on an essential level
by it
and i think that's the journey and
that's the journey that i work on with
clients
no matter what the outwardly symptoms
are
it could be weight gain it could be
relationship dysfunction
it could be struggling to experience
that sense of contentment or fulfillment
in life even though i have everything
that life says i should have
it could be feeling like i'm i'm lacking
or i'm just not doing enough or i'm not
being enough
but it all comes back to that stronger
sense of self
and this um you know horrific experience
what has it done to your opinion of
monogamy because i'm sure i'm guessing
from what you've said
the way that you planned your life ahead
you thought
when you you know when you went walked
down the aisle and you said those words
till death do us part
you then planned the next 60 years of
your life and how your life was going to
pan out
and when you said those words at the end
of the
at the altar you were totally convinced
yeah
totally convinced that this person was
the other person your soul mate
um how do you feel about all of those
concepts now like soulmate and monogamy
and until death do his part
experience led me to a position where i
began to question my deepest assumptions
about monogamy about marriage about
lifelong relationships and in the same
way i began to take a step back
and reflect and contemplate
i became very aware that there is a
social script
for relationships and it generally goes
the conventional model is boy meets girl
it's not even boy meets boy your girl
meets girl there's a first date a first
kiss
uh a period of courting at some point
um there will be sex
meeting the parents hopefully not at the
same time
eventually the relationship becomes
exclusive and engagement marriage
children
until death do us part and i realize
that that is a social construction
it's a conventional model based on
assumptions
that monogamy is natural
that marriage is a human universal
and that any structure
other than the nuclear one is
aberrant and so then i began to think
okay well what are the different
what are the different elements so on
the one hand we can take
and we touch upon it briefly uh
a evolutionary perspective
and we are apes it's not just that we've
descended from apes we
are apes we're one of the five
homo sapiens or one of the five
surviving species of great apes along
with
orangutans bonobos gorillas
and and chimpanzees
and yet at some point we
separated from that psychologically and
actually
the fine print that distinguishes humans
from other great apes
has been described by primatologists as
wholly
inadequate it's it's a fabrication
and at some stage we began to see
ourselves as special and unique and
above nature
and exempt from our
[Music]
primal history because we descended from
hypersexual ancestors so if
the homoline age has been around for two
million years
modern humans have been around for 200
000 years
and about 10 000 years ago there was a
shift in
going from hunter-gatherers to settled
communities
because of the advent of agriculture now
up until 10 000 years ago
the data now suggests that we actually
lived by fiercely egalitarian principles
everything was shared food shelter
water child care and even sexual
partners
casual sexuality was the norm
for our prehistoric ancestors for 95
of the collective experience of our
lineage
that is what we experienced
and it wasn't it wasn't based on
meaningless random relationships
they were relationships that reinforced
uh a social pattern that
that we needed to survive it minimized
our risk and it reinforced social ties
but then with the advent of agriculture
we began to settle
we had then we had land we had
uh domesticated animals
and for the first time private property
came into play
and suddenly there was a change and
there's even a change in the status of
women
because when we look at the human female
up until that point
was on with an equal playing field they
were as responsible
for the hunting and the cooking and
making decisions about where they were
going to settle
and then it changed and the female
became
the property of the man something that
he had to maintain
and keep and actually the reason that
property came into play is because we
weren't moving so it did matter
what happened to our resources we were
accumulating and biological paternity
for the first time became crucial
and so on on a natural
evolutionary level
[Music]
monogamy didn't exist we didn't
live in long-term monogamous
relationships
then we bring in marriage
and if we fast forward about five and a
half thousand years
in about 2350 bc
and in mesopotamia we're the first
marriage between the union between a man
and a woman and over the next few
hundred years
it spread the ancient romans greeks
hebrews
they began to adopt this widespread
practice but marriage had a dif
had a very different meaning across the
ages
in the um fifth century
with anglo-saxons it was about
securing trade ties it was a diplomatic
tool
in the 11th century marriage was about
financial economic and political
advantage
and as early as the 12th religion be
became involved
and and roman catholicism tied it to
sacrament and it to being a sacred
experience
related to experiencing god
then about 500 years ago thomas cranmer
came up with the modern day marital vows
that we read out today
and he was architecture of english
protestantism
and then up until 1858 divorce was rare
marriage was something which was
lifelong and it wasn't really questioned
but then it became a legal process that
you could apply to do
and it was still still relatively
uncommon because it was expensive and
women had to prove
aggravated adultery bestiality
sodomy cruelty and then
the divorce gates really opened up in
1969 with the divorce reform act
and marital breakdown could be could
then be cited so whenever we begin to
take a different lens and we see the
journey
that it's taken and then we ask well
where are we today
since 1975
there's been a drop in marriages by
about 30
more people are now opting to cohabit
than they are to get married
divorce statistics in england and wales
are at 42
you could arguably say that this system
is collapsing
that it is beginning to crumble
and they don't even take a cultural lens
yeah and if i'm talking too much just
no it's fascinating super fascinating so
culturally um the spanish word esposas
means wife and handcuffs
we joke about the wife being the ball
and chain
a friend got married got married got
engaged last week
and the talk amongst the boys was this
is the beginning of the end of your sex
life
yeah but women don't fare any better
you know 43 of american women report
sexual dysfunction
viagra sales are increasing every year
they're just
record highs year upon year bonus
through the [ __ ] reef
not that i would know yeah a friend told
me
yeah um
the porn industry takes in about 57
to 100 billion dollars worldwide
a u.s report showed that americans spend
more at strip clubs than they do at
broadway
off-broadway non-profit and regional
theaters the ballet
jazz and the opera
collectively we look at the church
and there have been hundreds of roman
catholic priests admitting to thousands
of sex crimes
in 2008 they paid out 436 million
dollars
to victims of sexual abuse a fifth were
under the age of five
and these aren't that's not to mention
the forgotten victims
and we have to ask yourself one
how did we get here two how was that
story constructed
and three is marriage
giving us what we want and is it
realistic and is it feasible
so number three where am i with that
yeah
yeah i'm still touring i'll be totally
honest with you
i can
say it i can imagine okay so i can
imagine that on the one hand
i can imagine being in a relationship
with with a woman and and being with
that one woman for the rest of my life
i can also imagine being
with someone in a relationship and
having more than one sexual partner
but but if if it was flipped around and
someone asked me
would you want your partners to be with
other men
yeah i'd say hell no of course like it
just seems yeah
it that is not something because i'm so
strongly programmed
against that even though that's
potentially the biological heritage
i can't imagine being with someone who's
with us with other people i wouldn't
want to be in that situation
and i'm aware of the acute hypocrisy
contained within it
yeah i think everyone feels the same way
to some degree i think people that tell
you otherwise are probably talking [ __ ]
because they're playing defense against
not wanting to happen to them to some
degree right but yeah
um it's a and i think it's an ideal
situation for yourself but not for the
person you're wit
with from your perspective i read this
book a long time ago called the mystery
method
um by one of the world's number one
pickup artist
and i don't know if this is true but
what he was saying was
men are programmed in a way that
seeks um the woman to be faithful for
them because
the risk the evolutionary risk was if i
impregnate you as my wife
um or no so if i if i'm committed to you
as my wife
and then you are you cheat on me and get
pregnant with someone else's child
i will then spend my resources my energy
my time
raising someone else's um child and then
my genetics won't pass on that person's
will and
essentially if you think about it from
an evolutionary perspective
i then wouldn't have existed if i didn't
have that concern
about making sure my sperm was the one
that reached the egg
i so you think about it from an
evolutionary perspective
you wouldn't exist if your ancestors
hadn't done a brilliant job
of making sure their sperm hit the egg
and one of the ways of doing that was
making sure it wasn't another guy's
sperm hitting the egg yeah
by being territorial by being whatever
and on the other side from the woman's
perspective
the book talks about how you know if a
woman got eight months
pregnant um tens of thousands of years
ago
she can no longer hunt and gather for
herself so really she has to find a
partner that isn't going to abscond that
isn't going to bounce
especially once they've had sex and so
the book kind of talks about some of the
the reasons why you know in society we
typically think women are
more in search of a relationship and are
trying to you know
get a guy more than men are typically um
is because
from an evolutionary perspective they
would have died
on the savannah in africa or whatever if
if the guy had sex with them impregnated
them at a time when we didn't have birth
control
got them eight months pregnant and then
bounced yeah
and and i don't know how true that is
yeah it's something that i've believed
because i've read this book for some
time
so that's the dominant
traditional understanding of
human sexuality because whenever you
look at
other species yes it's about essentially
an aggressive alpha male
than uh being with a
female and knowing that their offspring
is being continued through that lineage
there's an alternative which has come
out more recently
where i know there was a paper published
in science in 2015
that actually showed that what separated
humans
from other great apes was our social
organization
yeah about 10 000 years ago we started
living up next to water and in camps
exactly yeah so and then we were a tribe
essentially i've read about that
and up until that point though
it's very possible that we had uh
multiple sexual partners
but biological paternity was less of a
concern because our
structure was such that so what we found
out now is we didn't used to live
with our close relatives we actually
created social ties
with other individuals and so we're set
up in such a way that
the focus wasn't ever on individual
survival
it was on group survival group identity
group welfare and the reason is it's the
group that keeps you alive anyway
and so it's very possible that then
there was a shift which happened
actually with this advent of private
property because that's
whenever eternity would matter
because there's some hunter-gatherer
communities that believe
when multiple men have sex with a
female that it's to collectively
because you have to think where does our
understanding of the sperm
and embryo come from that's very recent
it's a very recent biological
understanding
our ancestors wouldn't have known that
and there are some beliefs where
collectively the men contribute to
the production of the child that
actually it's almost like an
amalgamation
of the different man then creates that
child and that child becomes
part of the group as opposed to that one
person's
child and this is the thing just to like
challenge that thinking
say that there was one man in the group
that was slightly better
and making sure he was the one that
inseminated the female yeah he his genes
would pass on
yeah his his genetics would pass on as
being slightly better for whatever
reason
and inseminating a woman and uh
therefore in the next round of you know
the next generation
he would have a slight advantage pretend
that that the kid of that man would have
a slight
genetic predisposition for being good at
that which would increase the
probability that they would pass on
again and again and again
and it seems like that that those
genetics and that ability to be good at
intimidating whether it's through being
territorial or being stronger or being
more persuasive or being more
you know more of a peacock yeah um
through generations over the space of a
million years
from the chimps that would create a
scenario where we are programmed
to be through our psychology and our
behavior and our peacocking
good at you know yeah winning yeah
even through slightly more malicious
methods or yeah
and then there's also the social
conditioning and the ideas
of of marriage of monogamy of
romanticism
of what that means and and i think
what i'd really come particularly
through my work with clients is seeing
that where people find themselves
in trouble is when there's enmeshment
whenever there's
too much when there's too much closeness
when actually the identity of one person
is submerged with the identity of the
other
and there's no space that happen to you
in your marriage where you became more
like her
it's incredible that you ask that
i have a little announcement to make and
if you're watching this on youtube you
might have seen a little clue as to what
i'm about to say
when we brought this podcast back and we
decided that we were going to do it
every single week on monday we also
decided that we wanted to find a sponsor
and a partner to help support the growth
of this podcast so that we can take it
all over the world we can produce the
video format we can hire a big team
and we can make sure it gets out to as
many people as possible
and so here's what i did i thought of a
couple of companies that i
really really love and companies that
i've used for many many years and i've
been an avid
customer of and one of those companies
in fact the first company i contacted
was this one hule and if you if you
don't know what huel is then you must
have been
living under a rock per se but huel has
been a huge part of my life for
about four years i first started
drinking huel
four years ago when i first moved to new
york and i was running social chain and
the reason
i did was because i was frequently
missing meals i and if you
if you know me personally you'll know
how true this is i will wake up in the
morning
and i'll rush through my day meeting
meeting meeting meeting speaking on
stage flying somewhere
and i'll get to about 9 00 pm and i
wouldn't have eaten a single
thing and there's no you know
nutritional
expert in the world that will tell you
that's a good thing and what then
happened was i was
binge eating at nine or ten o'clock and
when i say binge eating i mean like two
large domino's pizzas to myself
and so then i discovered this thing
called heal about four years ago and for
me huel is a nutritionally complete
drink which means that i don't have to
spend hours preparing food which i
wouldn't do anyway hence why i was
skipping meals
it means that i get all the good stuff i
need to perform and have a good diet
but i can have it in like 20 seconds and
as someone that values time so so much
heal was a godsend i've been a customer
for i think four years i've had my
subscription with you for four
years so when i was looking for someone
to sponsor the podcast
i contacted the ceo who's been on the
podcast before julian
and has built this staggering company i
sent him an email i said listen julian
i would love you to sponsor my podcast
because i can actually talk about your
product authentically
and he said to me because you've had a
subscription with you for the last three
four years and i know you're a customer
he was up for doing it
so i thank you and um every week on the
podcast i'm going to talk about
different
things to do with huel to do with time
saving to do with
diet and nutrition and of course we're
going to get julian back on the podcast
at some point their company
is doing unbelievable things in the uk
if you've not seen and sort of kept up
with the progress if you'll i highly
recommend you do because it's one of the
most exciting companies we've seen in
the uk in a long
long time and it's an absolute honor and
a privilege to to have them sponsoring
the director ceo
the perfect company to be on this
podcast because you know
it's a company that is so in line with
some of my central values
did that happen to you in your marriage
where you became more like
her it's incredible that you
ask that whenever we first met
she was the sensible one she was very
prudent
very pragmatic very level
headed she made very safe sensible
choices
in life in general and she was known in
that way
i was a bit more of a rogue i was uh
a little bit more mysterious it was
probably
a sort of you know hint of mischievous
of um
spontaneity yeah of playfulness
and and there's an idea in
psychology that we all that we seek
in the other person a part of ourselves
that we've lost
and so there was almost that um that
attraction there it created that
chemistry
it drew us in together i think she was
looking for that excitement
and and in a way that safe danger
i was actually looking for stability and
groundedness
and over time it connected us and
brought us together but over time
a remarkable thing happened and that is
just like you said i began to become
more like her
i became became safer and i actually
lost
an intrinsic part of who i was
i lost the
the wild child that's in me i lost the
part that's a bit more dangerous it's a
bit more risky
that it doesn't always say something
which is politically correct
and i became almost like a
sanitized clean version of who i was
and that's not the man that she met and
that's not the man that she fell in love
with
and on one level it it worked in terms
of a stable love
there was reliability there was
dependability there was
relatability
but it crushed the desire there was a
slow
suffocation of that desire over the last
couple of years
and so i believe that
one day she woke up
and she sensed that loss of connection
which i also
sense too and that loss of intimacy
and she was scared and when the mind is
scared
it comes up with thoughts is this it
am i gonna have to live like this for
the next 10
20 years will i ever get that chemistry
or that connection back
what if it never comes back
and when we're afraid we're then seeking
that
that part of ourselves that we've lost
and so it's almost
less about the other person and more
about us
it's less about turning away from our
partner and more about
turning away from a part of ourselves
it's less about finding another person
and more about finding another part of
ourselves in which we feel alive
and i think the fear would have been
wildly tempting
wildly exciting it would have been
all the things it would have given her a
lot of the things that we had in the
beginning
that she missed and suddenly it was back
and even the structure of an affair
is such that you can't
have the other person and the forbidden
is erotic
and it's set up in such a way that it
just perpetually creates desire because
it has to be secretive it can't be long
lasting for long periods of time
there's continual space now if
fire needs air desire needs space
and we found ourselves in a situation in
which we're seeing each other
every day i used to be traveling i used
to be working away a lot more
we would have pockets where we'd be
apart and in that pocket even if you're
away for a day or a couple of days
there's a sense of loss on a very micro
level
and then a sense of excitement of the
person coming back
and reimagining that life together
and so going back to your point i did
i change and that song that's something
which i've learned from
i've cha i changed and i became
like a squeaky clean version of me and
and she ironically ended up turning
towards
what she'd lost that's something you
regret
i could feel regret in the way that i
said it there
yes yeah being being honest if i could
have
if i could have changed on one level if
i could have changed that
if i'd been aware of that and i'd and
i'd seen it coming
then i would have wanted you
to stay true to who i am and that's the
path i'm on now
and i'd be curious to hear your thoughts
but i
i want to live in line with my truth
and it's like john 8 32 the truth will
set you free
and i believe that when we're living in
line with our truth it saves you
and whenever we neglect
our truth it destroys you yeah and so if
i
if i'd if i'd been able to
stay truthful i think it would have been
a very different trajectory
i don't because the relationship worked
on multiple levels and we
and and it did we had a wonderful um
time together for
for eight years but it's a little bit
like putting a frog in boiling water it
was in cold water
and the desire is the frog it's alive
you don't notice the heat there were
unknown factors that were at play
and it was a dance it was both of us
there's no it we're we both contributed
to that situation i think
she wanted me to be that stable
dependable reliable person
without realizing that on a subconscious
level she actually
was attracted to the man that i was and
i wanted to make her happy and didn't
want her to
be the kind of person that creates
tension or or
or there being too much grit but
actually tension is what creates fire at
the same time
and so the rough edges were a part of
who i was and i didn't need to get rid
of them
it's so crazy it's almost quite
contradictory the typical narrative you
hear about relationships is
especially from you know dare i say it
um women movies and on instagram is
there's this conversation around can i
change him
um and it's and it seems typically that
people want to change
that or they they hold out hope or they
want to change their partner in some way
to make them more like the image they
have of that person
yes but in fact what you're describing
is the thing that ends up
saving the relationship is a finding
someone that
you love for the way that they are and
you're attracted to
the way that they are but then both
parties having a resilience to change
um to some degree but because of that
understanding that you
formed your relationship on the basis of
this person being like this
and then but then you say okay so
over time people change and in fact in
the last podcast we did
there's a quote where you said change is
the only constant
so both of you are going to change
anyway and you talk about the spiritual
psychological change that both parties
go on
and again this kind of draws it back to
the conversation around monogamy is
you know you're going to change anyway
like you 10 years ago
versus you now is probably a little bit
more stable and a little bit more
you know solid and a little bit more
rational in your thinking
um and because as you said in the last
podcast change is a constant
how do you form a how can you guarantee
that death will do you part when change
might do your part first
and this kind of brings us back to the
conversation around monogamy which is
i guess it's my question to you is like
if you what do you
suspect now
if not marriage is going to be
the way that you know when you meet
someone what do you suspect what's your
hypothesis
on how that relationship will be
constructed for me personally yeah i've
got mine yeah yeah yeah
but mine kind of i can tell you mine if
you want first
yeah yeah okay so one kind of
so it was interesting what you said
there about um space being
the air to a flame right yeah and for me
that's so critical
earlier on when you're talking about
marriage yeah one of the factors you
you were talking about was how where
marriage came from as a social construct
yeah and how it centers on like you know
you know religion and
god and all of these things and one of
the things that i think is also really
important to understand is
as a general first principles rule if
people are different
and we all are different every single
human being on this earth is different
then the solution should be different
like the
the glove we fit is different we have
different size feet and different size
hands so the solution to love
or whatever that is as binary as it
sounds should therefore be
bespoke to who you are and the life
you're living in for me i live
a life where i'm i get my fulfillment
out of
the podcast and my work and that's it's
such a big part of my wiring
i can't change that it's the way that i
am i'm different from my brother and
he's only a couple of months older than
me i'm completely different
and so as it relates to love and me
having a bespoke
solution to when i meet someone and i
when i have kids or i want to you know
want them to be my partner um the
solution should also be bespoke
and so i look at the situation that
would be right for me and it is one
that's
really really reliant on space
yeah i love being on my own i am happy
there
i love having time to myself to reflect
to think
um to work on my projects space is such
a big thing for me
so marriage and the idea of moving in
with someone
and then being you know on top of me
seven days a week
for the next 60 years is a is something
that i almost can't understand i'm not
sure if i'm like psychologically [ __ ]
up and that's why i can't deal with that
but i love this idea as the founder of
huell said
on this podcast of treating my
relationship
with my romantic partner in the same way
that i treat my relationship with my
best friend
my best friend seems to get on perfectly
well and we and i can't see a divorce
ever coming you know what i mean yeah
because we have that space and we have
the
the middle ground that we meet upon
which is the relationship
but we have a fundamental amount of
space
um which we both need like in fact my
best friend moved in with me in lockdown
for a month and yeah uh
you start to piss me off
so [ __ ] loud like clean up after
yourself
how lowly do you choose we had an
argument i remember we are going over
something stupid like
a video game or something um so i'm
going to conclude the point i know for
me that space
and the lack of being on top of each
other is something that would be a
fundamental part of the relationship i
have i'm willing to commit
because i actually can't see a world
where i would allow them not to or that
i'd be happy with them not even the word
allow it's like permission right it's
like such a
[ __ ] thing to say but i can't see a
world where i would be okay with them
not
committing to me so i i'm gonna have to
concede there and i think i'll
figure that out hopefully if we can keep
the sex good
so space and commitment i hate the idea
of marriage i don't think religion or
the law have
any and should have any involvement on
the topic of love i think they'd have a
terrible track record religion with
homosexuality and and the you know the
history it has on love and the law
i didn't see why a court would have
anything to do with how i feel about
someone
so i hate the idea of marriage some kind
of commitment
that offers me space with the right
person where we both understand that at
some point we might grow out of each
other
and when we do um that's fine and i'm
going to conclude with one point which
you actually said in the last podcast
which was
when i asked you about monogamy and
about committing to someone for life you
said to me
um don't view it like that just ask
yourself the question every single day
yeah today am i happy to spend today
this day with this person in this
relationship if the answer is yes fine
yeah if the answer is known then there's
something that needs to be addressed
yeah thanks for sharing that
don't use it
i've actually got a photographic memory
absolutely it doesn't work for it
um what i know for for me
is there's definite similarities in that
realistically i can't see myself being
in a non-monogamous relationship
and if i was with someone that would be
the person i would be with
in the past though in our last podcast
when he asked me about the definition of
love
that hasn't changed in that i believe
that love
is fostering that emotional and
spiritual growth
of someone else but what has changed is
what i've realized
in order to distinguish though between a
partner that you're with and a partner
that you have connection
and chemistry and intimacy with there
has to be
that physical intimacy
which which is maintained and which is
and
will wax and wane but which can still be
a light because whenever it dies it
irrevocably shakes the foundation of the
relationship
and i don't think i put enough
importance on that
i almost had like a zen-like view of
marriage as opposed to appreciating and
it was
it was funny it was a um someone was
speaking to him
and they were saying from a male
perspective
females want the new man during the day
to be kind
sensitive loving and they want a
and tie them up in the evening
and it but you know it got me thinking
because
what if the same ingredients that lead
to a long-lasting
loving relationship or monogamous
marriage stability dependability
relatability
safety protection caregiving
what if these are the same ingredients
that kill desire
because what i think is true is that
and i should just speak for myself
what i potentially find attractive in
the bedroom
might be the things that i actually
stand against during the day
there might be power and there might be
dominance and that
doesn't match up with how i see myself
during the day
and so then you reach this conflict
and i think what i began to do was i
began to
become the new man and only the new man
and actually what i want to do more
often is to tap
more into
and there's this great philosopher
called usher
who says a lady in the streets
and a freak in the bed and it's like i
and i heard that lyric maybe
eight years ago and i literally say it
to my friends all the time when i'm
talking about the type of partner that i
want
and it's matching up exactly what you
said the civility and the class
with the lack of class and
the freakishness and the and
it's it's hard to find and maintain the
balance yeah
um i found yeah and because
sex can be really
a journey of somewhere that you go and
so then there has to be
that trust and that safety there and at
times it might be
about uh letting go of responsibility
and surrendering
it might be about taking control and
being dominant
but it's an understanding what it means
to you and
at what times they should unfold and and
be allowed to live
so your imagination can live because
when it doesn't and then it just becomes
an
act or something that you should do
or a way of having children then
we begin to feel lost and that's you
know what's happened with a lot of
clients i've seen and so going back to
how i would want to
imagine the situation is yes it'd be a
monogamous relationship with
with another um with a woman and
i would want to try and stay true to who
i am
and still keep keep that whole version
of me
and that's what i've learned keeping and
i've gone back to that the wonderful
thing is
would i you know you ask me what do i
regret it
the reason also why i don't regret it
because i'm not holding on to it
it's because the changes have happened
and i've trusted that it was meant to be
and i was meant to unfold that way and
i'm much more in tune with who i am now
so i finally got my motorbike license
i bought my triumph bonnie uh
yesterday and i'm doing the things which
and i realized because i'm drawn to more
of a sense of risk and danger
and actually activities where i have to
be consumed within that moment and be
present
and i'm getting back in touch with who i
am and how i want to live my life and
what i want to stand for and it's on me
to maintain that
with the next person i'm with another
thing i learned was the space
because where we went wrong is whenever
we didn't have the space
and actually i realized i really enjoy
living alone i love
that freedom my other relationships are
very important to me
with my brother and my best friends
and so i don't know yet what that will
look like
but it will definitely involve more
space
and and also that sense of adventure and
spontaneity because that's what i enjoy
i want to travel i want to see different
countries and i've
i can set my life up where i'm doing
that potentially with another person
or still pursuing my passions
and that is a safe relationship
relationship where
that person knows that i love them and
i'm there for them but i won't always be
but then kids comes in the same room
[ __ ] up this whole
fantasy like do you know what i mean
because then we'll deal with that in
podcast three yeah
but that's that's the bit where i'm like
okay it's all wonderful and perfect
i was just thinking then my last three
relationships they've all lived in
another country
and it's and it's probably the reason
why it works is because
i can walk around here my boxing shorts
all day just like drinking my heel you
know eating my partner or whatever
and um being myself and then we come
together
when they come there or i go there a
week yeah wonderful love it
great and then i go back and have my you
know my
bachelor lifestyle you know um
but yeah like i i think um kids is a is
a really
a topic which we would be like
intellectually dishonest if we did it
didn't
yeah address because there's there'll be
people listening to this and i think
okay well that's all well and good
but when you become a father or a mother
you have to be there for your kids yes
and there's not a lot of science that
says it's not good to be
there for your kids right so yes and in
the same way that we can start to
though make sure that we clarify between
what the science says
and then what the script is
because absolutely we know that
uh children will have better emotional
outcomes
and even physical development and
situational success whenever they are
brought up with a sensitive
caregiver someone who is responsive to
their needs
someone who hears them can hold them
give them safety but also permission to
build to travel and come back
and who's invested in that child
but i'm not aware of studies that
say that the parents have to be living
in the same home
in the one house 12 months of the year
and be
their lives to be set up in a certain
way and i don't know what the answer is
yet and i'm not at that stage yet but i
would be
curious whenever i am at that stage to
begin exploring and it might not be
as radical as is envisioned at a certain
point in time
but there might be enough space or
enough
still spontaneity or adventure or
playfulness even
on an internal level or in the way that
you set your life up
where both partners have that space
and still are able to maintain that
passion
isn't it crazy how much of life's misery
and failure
and um unhappiness
stems from either trying to conform to
the conventional way
or the script as you say yeah or trying
to fit into
or even sometimes answer an invalid
question we talked a little bit about
this
on the last podcast where i said you
know i think so many people live their
lives trying to answer invalid questions
like
what number is orange is what i said
last time and in the same way
you know the question are you in love
presumes a yes just by asking it i'm
forcing you to
to say yes yeah or no i'm also presuming
that we've agreed upon the definition of
in love which again is just a [ __ ]
amazing
because no one's ever told me what that
is no you're not born and they go okay
god goes by the way if you ever feel
this that's love okay and you go okay
got you
right because i you know the word is so
loosely i love peanut butter i love my
dog
i love my girlfriend i love my wife i
love my mom and it's like so what is it
different
it's such a [ __ ] confusing complex
nuanced thing love
and we're forcing it into this yes or no
yeah and people will like
that they'll ruin good things because
they they
they feel pressured or they're unsure if
this is it yeah and
um i just i just wanted to kind of leave
that point there in a sense of like that
idea of like you know
i know so many people listening to this
will will be
unknowingly programmed by convention and
it's like the first principle thinking
and the ability to question why you're
doing what you're doing
and then i guess lastly to have the
fearlessness or the courage to
potentially
interrogate and then reject it um
that can literally save you in every
facet it saved me like
go to university get a job do this and i
i
stopped going to school because i
thought it was a lot of [ __ ] dropped out
of university after one lecture started
a business
and i am as i've said on this podcast
before i'm the happiest person i know
i've reached a level of success at
ridiculously young age i managed to like
write us
write a news story write a new script
for how life can be lived
and um people admire me and listen to
this podcast
basically only because not because i'm
smarter than anyone else or anything
else
it's fundamentally if you go back to
where it started was because i
for some reason was willing to question
the script
and then had the as they call it
fearlessness for me it wasn't
for me the biggest fear was [ __ ]
following the script clearly right
but had the perceived fearlessness to
say well this doesn't make sense
um yeah how does that resonate with you
two things come to mind one is that
like you said before the solution in my
mind will be bespoke
because we're trying to take a
one-size-fits-all solution a panacea and
apply it to everyone
and and we're all unique and
it's important i think for the each to
begin to
become aware of the emotional resistance
we have to considering
possibilities outside of the
conventional
nuclear family unit and just begin to
think about what that might mean
and and where where we might be able to
see change and the second part is to ask
yourselves
what do i think i have to have in order
to be happy
so in relationships often people think
marriage
children in business it could be
x revenue y set up
zed lifestyle and then
we can ask what will that give me
why will it make me happy because below
will be the emotional need
so it could be in relationships this
could be because i want affection
physical intimacy a sense of belonging
stability for something else it could be
status
to be accepted by others not to be
judged
but isn't just a yeah isn't the actual
truth
based on that so on that point of
marriage people thinking that they think
marriage will make them happy
they've never experienced marriage
before right so where have they got that
idea from
it's i think the actual the fundamental
truth is
because they told me it would make me
happy yeah we've been sold
that story but what do people really
want what are they
wanting out of the marriage if you go
deeper there will be
an emotional need that they're trying to
meet through the marriage that they
think their marriage will
provide the solution to but like you're
saying it doesn't
well it can but it might not
and so what people might actually want
is
emotional connection or companionship
you know if you said describe the
marriage the ideal marriage to me they
might say well
we're happy and we're there for each
other and i have a confidant or a best
friend or i have a lover
it's understanding those different parts
when we've broken that down
and understand what we're what we're
actually yearning for or searching for
we can then ask can i meet those needs
in a slightly different way that doesn't
necessarily prescribe
to the conventional model and that's
first principle thinking in essence
which is
exactly back to like the fundamental
yeah
yeah which is how yeah yeah and which is
what i said before is what i love about
your mind because you take it back to
your first principles
and then that's whenever you potentially
become
you know i just threw things yeah
that's it's such a i i wish the school
taught kids how to think
in that way because when i if the first
principles just go back to the
university point for me where i want to
be i want to start a business and be a
millionaire that's what
my stupid ass brain was thinking at that
point right
so this piece of paper who am i going to
show that to if i'm self-employed
yes good point i don't want you to show
it to myself
everyone else everyone else around me is
sleeping on their desk and hung over
and i'm going to have the same stamp
that they all have
but that's actually probably going to
work against me and
i swear to god this isn't i'll tell you
if it was hindsight [ __ ]
i was thinking that i've got this vivid
memory of my first day at university and
my last
um of looking over and this girl bits up
being sat on my right
and she was drunk and sleeping on the
desk and i didn't get into a good
university because i got expelled from
school so i didn't really
take my exam seriously either again
because of the same thinking um
but i remember thinking i'm gonna go i'm
gonna get the same trophy as her
is that how is that going to help me if
we both show everybody and i just think
and then you've got it was boring as
[ __ ] like i've been running businesses
since i was 14 day one they were like
make a poster i swear to god the lesson
my last lesson in my first year at
university was
make a poster and i thought this isn't
gonna
in terms of the information part that's
not gonna give me the information
and it was that and i walked out there i
walked into the business office
and i spoke to the head of the business
at the university and i said i'm going
to defer for her for a little while
she said cool fill out this piece of
paper and you can defer i never even
filled it out and never went back
turns out i actually hadn't properly
registered for university either like as
i was meant to so
i didn't really have to defer
and that was it and you know i wanna i
wanna move on because you spent a lot
long time talking about this topic i you
said earlier on that you spent lockdown
in
california yes which is uh you know
i'm jealous you don't know
and and it cuts both ways you don't know
what's going to happen
in the next moment we have a projection
of the way that we think our life will
unfold
and often we become tied to it and bound
to it
and any deviation we can see as a
failure of some sorts
but actually sometimes life has other
plans for us
and when we don't know what's going to
happen i think it keeps that freshness
you keep fresh eyes and you stay
grateful for what you do have while you
have it
on the other hand
we don't know what's going to happen and
it could all be taken away from us at
any point
and i've got a good friend of mine and
his father uh
just had a stroke a couple of days ago
and they now know the outcome is he
won't be around
10 days goes walking in in south ken and
five minutes after i passed and was
coming back there was um
barriers put up and
a uh refuse collector had been walking
out in a bus and knocked him down
and in an instant
his life was over and i just imagined
that i could be completely wrong but i
could
i imagined gosh he might have a family
he might say goodbye to his wife and the
kids in the morning
and he went off to work and he had no
idea and she had no idea
and and the things that were really that
might have been niggling or
causing arguments don't matter now like
none of that matters now
and and i didn't see what was going to
happen
coming and and i you know i lost it on
one level i lost a lot and it makes me
really appreciate what i had
but then on another level that wasn't
the end to the story
and then it was as if life said you're
on this path
and i'm going to shunt you into a new
trajectory
and that's the path you're meant to be
on this is where you're meant to be
going and i believe that it's a part of
my path
and it was meant to unfold this way the
universe is unfolding as it should
and it's a lesson for me to continually
trust and that's why that voice came up
in the very beginning
in my heart saying all is well because i
know
on a deep level that all is well
it's just about trusting sometimes
letting go of our ideas and
living in this moment
i can think of a better ending
listen i i don't even you know thank you
so much for so many reasons because
what you've done today on one hand will
probably be selfish
selfish as i as you move forward and
realize that
the release of your truth and talking
about it and processing it with people
is always liberating but on the other
hand it's incredibly
selfless because there are so many
people that are going to going to
have less pain deal with their pain
better and understand themselves and
hopefully be a little bit more
self-aware because you had the guts
and the um and the you know the humility
and lack of ego
to share what is an incredibly emotional
um touching personal um experience
and so thank you so much it's helped me
you know and
i have no doubt that the hundreds of
thousands of people that listen to this
it's going to help them in the same way
um if people want to find
you and they want to talk to you about
this and i'm sure
there will be a lot of them you know the
podcast was big back then it's
much bigger now right how do they find
you
what's the best way to reach you so on
instagram
it says at dr.underscore aria
or my website which is drhyphenaria.com
and what kind of services do you offer
people
that are going through you know various
predicaments
so i do one-to-one coaching so
right now everything's done digitally
but essentially
it's identifying what aspect of your
life right now is critical for you to
resolve
and then helping you with the psychology
and the mindset
to be able to work through that or work
with that so it could be emotional
resilience it could be
sustainable weight loss it could be
relationships it could be
taking your business to the next level
in terms of how you
view yourself as an entrepreneur um
it might be fears loss of intimacy
impostor syndrome whatever issue is
actually
there for you i'll
check if it's something that we can
approach from a mindset point of view
and that's where my expertise is
and then help you on your journey as you
then have a more empowered mindset
so that you're developing that robust
sense of self and you're able to
change and adapt and be fluid in your
journey and keep on growing essentially
we have um we have such good
conversations even off the podcast we
met i think last week or the week before
and had just an open conversation about
a bunch of things in life
so i actually wanted to ask you i've
never asked a guest this before but
is there anything that we've missed in
terms of the topics that you think are
curious to the relationship we have or
pertinent to the relationship we have
or um any sort of learnings that
you've garnered from our conversations
that you think we should be
sharing with people because i feel
somewhat i thought those conversations
were so rich
that i i you know we talked about so
much last time and
um even in our private conversations i
just i just wonder if there's anything
else any sort of key topics that you
i'm sure there will be like i don't
think we've exhausted our conversation
we'll be back for a third hour
listen thank you so much for your time i
appreciate it i i yeah i appreciate it
so so much
more than i you know people they give up
so much time and they fly
to come and do the podcast but um the
what you've given today
i don't think you'll realize how
selfless um that act was
because of the value it will give to
people and this is exactly why i do this
podcast
um to hear these kinds of things and to
to hopefully
make myself better and the listeners
better for hearing it so
thank you a million million times over
thanks steve thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you